I was looked down here on the baseline -
I'm worried that maybe the cameraman is
hurt there's a lot of tension it is your
aide to him right now sir and Lucas
going down there to check on him because
it was a bad collision I immediately saw
AC run over there and Dion Calhoun run
over there then the man in the world TJ
McConnell is on the free-throw line we
understand that's one of the largest
cameramen working on our telecast
tonight
JoEllen feedback to the Sixers that's
assistant athletic trainer Deon Calhoun
along with Luca was a missed shot and
Luca just backed his way down oh wow I'm
called a mouth guard - and then the
cameraman looks like his head might hit
the chair right behind him he's trying
to control that camera looks like he
puts it away trying to go up top - green
steel look a quick Drive name blocked
shot by Tremont and then it's Durant all
alone mam's trying to catch him Durant
bobbled it Dallas just catch him but he
still scores
some ports right here local would match
her into the crowd at the other end he's
trying to help a little boy